et en 325 de Monsieur Bruno Sido un
monsieur le ministre chargé de transport
de la mer et de la pêche
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
ma question s'adresse s'adressait à
monsieur le ministre des Transports mais
qui est retenu par le mauvais temps par
les congères et donc je suis ravi que ce
soit madame la ministre chargé de la
décentralisation qui est me répondre
l'avant projet de loi de
décentralisation et de la réforme de
l'action publique en son chapitre 9
dédié aux transports prévoit de
clarifier les compétences de l'État et
des conseils régionaux en matière de
desserte ferroviaire
si l'intention est louable les
conséquences peuvent s'avérer
dramatiques pour le niveau de service en
particulier sur la ligne Paris Belfort
Paribas en effet d'après les
informations dont je dispose les lignes
d'intérêt national devraient à l'avenir
desservir au moins deux villes de plus
de 100000 habitants et qui plus est dans
deux régions non contiguës
cette question ne concerne pas que la
Haute-Marne bien entendu tout le monde
l'a compris toute la France est
concernée si ces dispositions de
l'avant-projet de loi n'était pas
modifiées elles entraîneraient une
dégradation très nette de la qualité et
de la desserte entre Paris et la
Haute-Marne 11 train au départ de
Chaumont serait supprimé chaque semaine
alors que le Conseil général met tout en
oeuvre pour moderniser le département et
l'ouvrir sur les grands axes de
circulation cette perspective est
inacceptable la Haute-Marne est en
reconversion industrielle depuis plus de
30 ans depuis la fin des trentes
glorieuses et depuis le premier choc
pétrolier cette crise des industries et
de la métallurgie à apporter comme dans
tout l'est du pays son cortège de
licenciement et de souffrance
tous les élus du territoire sont
mobilisés depuis une dizaine d'années
bien au-delà des sensibilités partisanes
au conseil général nous avons décidé de
faire de la modernisation des
infrastructures une priorité pour plus
d'attractivité
madame la ministre je ne vous soustrais
qu'un seul exemple nous investissons 40
millions d'euros pour poser 1200 km de
fibre optique et permettre aux ruraux
qui ne sont pas des citoyens de seconde
zone d'avoir le haut des billes comme
tout le monde le conseil régional le
conseil général et les parlementaires
partagent cette même préoccupation et
nous sommes tous mobilisés je remercie
donc Madame le Ministre de m'indiquer si
le Gouvernement entend modifier cet
avant-projet de loi afin de conserver à
la Haute-Marne en particulier une
politique d'aménagement du territoire
digne de ce nom
et madame la ministre
merci Monsieur président monsieur le
sénateur
le vous indiquez dans le début de votre
question vous évoquez un avant projet de
loi avant projet de loi qui
effectivement était très antérieur à
celui qui a été déposé jeudi dernier au
Conseil d'État et qui a repris tout ce
qui était dans ce chapitre 9 qui
n'existe plus en tant que tel et donc
qui se trouve aujourd'hui
considérablement modifié dans le projet
de loi transmis au Conseil d'État qui va
être soumis le 10 avril le prochain au
Conseil des ministres si le texte reste
dans l'état que je connais aujourd'hui
le ce qui concerne le transport est très
édulcoré parce que effectivement
l'intention du ministre cuvilier qui
s'excuse de pas répondre lui-même
directement à la question aujourd'hui
comme je viens de le dire tout à l'heure
l'intention du ministre est de pouvoir
disposer d'un véhicule législatif propre
qui lui permettra d'aborder complètement
le problématique des transports des
transports ferroviaires notamment dans
le cadre de la concertation sur laquelle
il s'est engagé et qui est une
concertation qui doit être longue lourde
et nourri contenu des enjeux que vous
avez rappelé et sur ces enjeux justement
il n'est pas question et c'était la
raison pour laquelle peut-être que la
partie de test que vous aviez élue a
disparu c'est que nous n'étions pas
allés au bout des logiques qui auraient
permis de répondre à ce maillage
indispensable pour l'ensemble de notre
territoire voilà le contexte général que
je voulais vous dire je vous apporte là
maintenant des réponses plus techniques
qui me sont communiquées par le ministre
Cuvillier qui voulait vous dire
la conviction qui est la sienne sur les
trains d'équilibre du territoire les
trains d'équilibre des territoires sont
un héritage lourd pour la France qui en
est depuis peu l'autorité organ les
fameux Tet ils sont lourdement
déficitaires et la SNCF qui en avait
précédemment la responsabilité ni
investissez plus ces trains joue
pourtant un rôle essentiel et vous
l'avez redit dans l'aménagement du
territoire dans le quotidien de nos
concitoyens ils doivent constituer une
offre commerciale complémentaire du TGV
par des horaires des correspondances
adaptées avec l'accent mis sur
l'accessibilité et la qualité du service
à bord l'évolution de ces trains du
quotidien et donc une priorité du
gouvernement c'est la raison pour
laquelle le ministre a annoncé le
lancement dans les tous prochains mois
d'une première tranche d'investissement
de 400 millions pour le renouvellement
du matériel roulant mais
l'investissement seul ne suffit pas pour
améliorer la qualité du service à la
hauteur de ce qu'attend des usagers une
offre doit aussi évoluer pour mieux
répondre aux besoins de déplacement de
ce point de vue et c'est très
spécifiquement ce que vous me
les régions sont les premières à
reconnaître la difficulté à tracer
parfois sur certains trains la frontière
entre leur TER les trains d'équilibre
régionaux et les detet d'équilibre
territorial car il concerne les liaisons
entre deux régions cette imbrication des
services est à l'origine de problèmes
qui pèse sur les coûts et sur la qualité
du service au final derrière les
autorités organisatrices il y a des
usagers qui doivent être satisfaits
chacun au mieux de ses moyens les
régions ont reçu compétences pour
organiser les services de transport
régional elles le font et elles le font
remarquablement l'État et c'est la
question qui se pose a-t-il vocation à
les concurrencer sur ces liaisons entre
deux régions seulement avec ces trains
n'est-il pas plus intéressant pour les
régions de disposer de l'ensemble des
leviers sur les trains qui assurent les
déplacements domicile travail à
l'intérieur d'une région ou entre deux
régions limitrophes en revanche à
vocation à conserver les trains qui
assurent l'aménagement du territoire
entre trois régions là où aucune offre
alternative n'existe il faut donc
réfléchir à la manière de mieux
organiser les offres naturellement dans
le respect de juste équilibre financier
des parties il va de soi qu'en cas de
transfert de certaines liaisons aux
régions celles-ci se verrai attribuer à
la compensation financière existante
vous voyez monsieur le sénateur que
c'est un problème que le gouvernement
prend à bras le corps et qu'il traitera
comme il en a l'habitude aujourd'hui
dans sa méthode de concertation et
d'écoute et de dialogue avec les élus
locaux
merci madame la ministre monsieur sido
merci madame la ministre pour votre
réponse alors je ne sais pas s'il faut
que je reste inquiet mais vigilant
certainement parce que ce que vous venez
de me dire je résume non non cette
affaire n'est plus dans la loi de
d'aménagement du territoire et de
décentralisation mais dans un véhicule
législatif propre ça mais crainte mais
heureusement comme vous venez de le dire
il faut que cette année qu'il le
territoire relie trois régions ce qui
est le cas de du train Paris Belfort et
par conséquent je pense que avec les
investissements qui sont prévus de 400
millions d'euros et bien nous pourrons
maintenir notre ligne je signale quand
même que c'est une une réalité je
prenais le je venais ici hier soir en
train dans un dans une dans un wagon non
chauffée et très mal éclairé on pouvait
même pas lire le journal on voit bien
que il faut se matérielle arrive à bout
et il faut absolument le remplacer des
investissements importants il faut leur
connaître ont été fait par RFF pour
améliorer la ligne c'est clair mais
encore faut-il qu'il y ait des trains
qui roulent dessus merci madame la
ministre
merci